hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Star Wars rogue one non-spoilery
review make sure you go see the movie it
ended up being so much better than I
expected it to be there is a Star Wars
giveaway happening right now it's
basically for two imax gift certificates
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so that you don't miss out
on anything so right off the bat Mads
Mikkelsen is just so amazing in this
movie Felicity Jones did a great job but
I feel like Mads Mikkelsen no matter
what his role is he's always going to do
something interesting regardless of how
he's written but Donnie Yen what a
badass I was so happy when I heard he
was going to be in this movie
you always get hyped when you know
Donnie yen's in a movie and you know he
gets to fight a ton of people and then
Ben Mendelsohn just what an amazing
antagonist the way they play with the
John Williams music the way they opened
the film to differentiate it from other
Star Wars films there's so many things
that are similar but yet very different
about this that made it so much better
than I ever thought it could be there
are so many things that we can say about
this film I'll tell you no total success
off the bat doing a film that does not
rely on the Skywalker's at least in a
major way or on the idea of Jedi with
lightsabers it does this amazing job of
broadening the mythology of the force in
a really interesting way and just proves
that you can tell a really interesting
story from start to finish with a single
film you don't need an entire trilogy to
tell an amazing story
so if this proves anything it's that
they can totally do just one-off films
in different corners of the Star Wars
galaxy they effectively visited more
different new planets that we'd never
seen before in like the first 20 to 30
minutes of the movie than we saw in the
entirety of Star Wars Episode seven so
the other big achievement is that it
also enriches the other movies even
though it exists by itself with a
different group of characters it's just
like the kernel of a story that we had
before we knew the rebels had stolen the
Death Star plans so they took that and
turned it into a movie and it totally
worked in now when you go see a new hope
episode 4 after you see this movie
you'll have so much more context the
moments like Darth Vader
at the beginning of episode 4 where he's
talking to the imperial council about
the new Death Star being completed will
mean so much more and that's even just
like a little part of it we don't even
need a sequel to this movie and I think
that's kind of the idea is that you know
they'll take like little pieces of
stories from the previous Star Wars
films and then turn that into something
like rogue one only just in a vastly
different part of the galaxy during a
different time period in a different
context that will enrich the other saga
films without necessarily being beholden
to the Skywalker family the other
amazing thing about this is that it also
broadens the empire in the rebellion as
characters themselves like you have the
characters that you fall around in the
film but then you have the idea of the
Empire itself as this living organism
with just a lot of people working for it
just because it's evil doesn't mean that
everybody that works for the Empire all
the officers agree with each other is
this big group of diverse people and you
know what's the big thing that we knew
about the Empire in the previous films
they're bad
the rebels are good but this film puts
the war back in Star Wars it does a
really good job of being sort of like a
war documentary mixed with this real
down and dirty heist movie so the rebels
even though we know they're on the right
side of this have to do really bad
things to accomplish their goals so it's
much grayer it's not just like really
good guys against really bad guys
they're also credit character is
arguably like the big antagonist of the
film but in no way does he feel like an
emperor or a Darth Vader type character
somebody who you know is doing really
evil things like it took a long time to
figure out that Darth Vader had
something underneath that mask that
wasn't just this terrible really raspy
breathing person that crushed everyone's
throats when they displeased him so you
get a much more well-rounded character
and in developing the or so critic
character you learn a lot about the
power structure of the Empire not
everybody loves everybody else inside
the Empire especially just if they're
making giant super weapons so it's
really funny how they mythologize the
Death Star in this too because it's kind
of like this white elephant
pie-in-the-sky project that these
weirdos are working
and the rest of the Empire just
completely does not care about it until
it's finished and we get to Episode four
with this council scene with like the
other imperial council members and the
general just really excited about it not
everybody in the Empire up at the top
shared those feelings when they first
got started so reshoots I know a lot of
you are asking about the reshoots like
what did they change about the film they
did a whole bunch of stuff to change
just big portions so if you look at the
trailers most of these scenes did not
make it into the final version of the
film which is kind of weird but a lot of
times that happens like they'll market
to film really early on but then later
they'll find better ideas they'll make
subtle changes in scenes that completely
change the context so they just have to
cut out like whole big swaths of the
film but as weird as it sounds the film
is great so all the stuff that they
changed was for the better what happened
is they said they initially shot most of
the film in a really handheld
documentary war film type way so when
they got to the Edit they realized that
there was just like a little connective
tissue missing between scenes and they
turned it into more of what you would
think of as a traditional Star Wars film
so that being said if you've been asking
for a more mature Star Wars film like a
Star Wars film that's made not you know
not so much for like really little kids
but for adults rogue one is it just in
the way it treats some of the themes of
war in the galaxy in the stuff that it's
dealing with so even though all the
characters are really funny the comedy
is great it's actually a pretty serious
Star Wars film so you have all these
rebels that are coming together all over
the galaxy like this is still towards
the beginning of the rebellion it's
between episode 3 and episode 4 on the
timeline but you have this Empire that's
trying to steal all the resources from
all these different planets the people
that live there saying this is bullcrap
we're gonna come together and stop you
from doing this and that's where you get
to the rebellion so the film does a
really good job of showing you that
process like how they come to that
conclusion in what it is that makes the
Empire so terrible even though not
everybody that works for the Empire are
terrible people so what's the other
really big thing about star wars films
all the creatures all the costumes they
had some of the most diverse group of
aliens in the film
that you've ever seen in star wars now
like George Lucas always made a really
big deal about trying to make the newer
films like the prequels even the Clone
Wars look as different as possible from
previous Star Wars films but like I said
the first 20 to 30 minutes of the film
you visit so many different planets and
as you go to all those different places
everywhere looks very different in terms
of the people the aliens the creatures
the sheer quantity of creature work in
this film is just amazing in the cosplay
is going to be on fire next year at
Comic Con like the shore troopers look
amazing the death troopers even from the
Empire standpoint now just forget about
the rebels for a second but all the new
Empire stuff they show up so the design
language flows a lot from Episode four
because this is kind of a prequel to
Episode four so like all the Star
Destroyers the Death Star itself looks
familiar
but they found little ways to just
include a bunch of new things within
that design scheme so like the shore
troopers are new the death troopers are
new but the interesting thing is is they
said they also changed Darth Vader's
costume so like even minor details like
that or even when they were on the sets
filming the scenes like in the
backgrounds you know they have a lot of
playback on the screens like when you're
on a Star Destroyer Ben Mendelsohn the
actor said that it totally took him back
to his childhood just because he was
standing in front of all these screens
you know doing his lines and they were
on this playback loop and just looking
at them they look like they were
straight out of 1977 they were so
perfect they did such a good job earlier
this year marketing the film showing up
behind the scenes stuff like if you're a
big geek for the way they make Star Wars
films then you will go crazy when you
see rogue one so the film does a really
good job of like being in this very Star
Wars Episode four or five and six
universe just because of the design
language and the time period that it
falls in without being completely
beholden to all the Skywalker stuff and
just slavishly setting up other movies
like Episode seven does not that I think
that Star Wars Episode seven was a bad
movie I just feel like rogue one does a
much better job of what it's set out to
do tell like a really small
self-contained story about a really big
event in the history of the gal
while at the same time enriching the
other films Star Wars Episode seven had
like the Herculean task of being the
first Star Wars movie in such a long
time there was no way that it was going
to live up to everyone's expectations so
with that in mind here's my new ranking
of all the Star Wars movies from
favorite to slightly less favorite there
are no Star Wars films that I actively
hate even the prequels I don't hate the
prequels some of them I just don't like
as much as the others so favorite film
Empire then a new hope Return of the
Jedi then rogue one which I like a
little bit better than Episode seven in
then Attack of the Clones so let me know
what are your favorite Star Wars films
from most favorite to least favorite
just rank them all in the comments just
because I feel like rogue one is good
enough that a lot of people will feel
like it's even better than Star Wars
Episode seven that's the real surprise
of the year I'm so blown away that they
were able to do that now it might not
make quite as much money as episode 7
because you have like a lot of people
that normally wouldn't go see a Star
Wars film that were so excited at the
idea of a new Star Wars film that last
year they just got up off their asses
and went to the movie theater whereas
like this year they're like okay you
know I saw storage last year I don't
need to see it again I'll just I'll wait
for episode 8 if I want to go back so I
still think it's gonna make it ungodly
sum of money and it's going to show
Lucasfilm that they can do small one-off
films about other parts of the galaxy
other groups of characters that we
haven't met before as long as it
enriches the other films so next big
elephant in the room what does that say
about the obi-wan Kenobi film that
everyone's been clamoring for that means
they can still do stuff like that
but they shouldn't be afraid to try
brand new things which is really where
we're headed after episode 9 like the
idea that we might not have films about
the Skywalker saga anymore they just
move on to something else
so why we'll be doing a Star Wars
obi-wan Kenobi video really soon and
I'll explain like what's going on with
him in the Star Wars universe they do
have a plan for him there's a reason why
they haven't announced a Star Wars
obi-wan film because money is not a
concern they would make a billion
dollars on an obi-wan film it's just
that they have a very specific plan for
that character
within the scope of the new saga films
so rest assured Star Wars Episode 8 in
episode 9 have a plan for the op1
character and I'll explain part of what
I think that is in my next Star Wars
video so what's gonna happen is I'll do
my spoilery Easter Egg video later this
weekend I'll do the obi-wan video before
that but later tonight I have some new
Spider Man homecoming that I'm gonna
post and then I'm gonna go see rogue one
again so if you've already seen it once
try to go see it twice because there are
a lot of Easter eggs some of them are
actually pretty easy to spot and one of
them is like a planet name so I'll just
say you know there's a planet that is
named that's an anagram for one of the
biggest Star Wars characters of all time
so look out for that when you go through
the movie I am just so happy that this
ended up being good what you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
rewatch those spider-man homecoming
trailers and you can click here to
rewatch that rogue one behind the scenes
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]